[Music]
just as the individual
self-consciousness does not find itself
in this Universal work of absolute
freedom qua existence substance so
little does it find itself in the deeds
proper and individual actions of the
will of this freedom before the
universal can perform a deed it must
concentrate itself into the one of
individuality and put at the head and
individual self-consciousness for the
universal will is only an actual will in
a self which is a one
but thereby all other individuals are
excluded from the entirety of this deed
and have only a limited share in it so
that the deed would not be a deed of the
actual universal self-consciousness
Universal freedom therefore can produce
neither a positive work nor a deed there
is left for it only negative action it
is merely the fury of destruction
paragraph 589 is a very short but I
would say pregnant passage there's
there's a lot going on here as we
prepare to move into the terror from
absolute freedom and this has to do with
a dynamic that that turns upon the very
notion of will how do we reconcile
individual wills as individual wills
with each other in some sort of
coordinated community in a society in
something that could be said to have a
universal or general will how is this
going to take place and remember this
now is happening after institutions have
been gutted after the whole realm of
faith has been deal amazed after the the
entire world not just of the medieval
period but the early modern period has
been shaken to its core in absolute
freedom in the very consciousness of
what would be possible for human beings
and you know we we we often think of the
19th century as the the great century of
you know these these massive social
changes and revolutions but that's also
happening within the 18th century as
well so how do we get there
Hegel talks about this is first of all
individual self consciousness attempting
to find itself and isn't able to do this
within this realm of absolute freedom as
conceived in terms of a universal work
to which it it somehow contributes now
he talks a little bit more substantively
about this absolute freedom he says we
have absolute freedom qua existent
dassai and a substance
right a substance that actually is there
that that exists for us that we can see
that we can participate in
institutionally so he says individual
self consciousness does not does not
find itself in this Universal work it
knows the universal work is there but it
doesn't manage to identify itself with
that why not why is there this
alienation this expropriation of its own
effort its own contributions into this
universal work why can't it say well we
all do our part and everybody you know
thereby participates in this one big
happy family or neighborhood or
community or state or pick whatever you
like Hegel tells us here that the it
doesn't find itself in that and it also
doesn't find itself in the deeds proper
and the individual actions of the will
of this freedom so those are interesting
things to say right
the deeds proper eigen leakin Totten
Totten is doing the deeds that that
makes perfect sense we can also say
actions I can leave him you know
individual proper my own that which
belongs to me as the agent it's no
longer finding itself in that it's also
not finding it in whatever the universal
work is doing as a response individual
actions individual that honda m-- han
logan sorry
actions yes compartments yes
general ways of doing things that works
too so really anything within the
practical sphere the individual self
consciousness is not able to find itself
is not able to recognize itself is now
get its meaning out of this relation
where everybody is contributing through
their own proper deeds and there are
their own individual deeds and their own
individual actions to this greater whole
they're not able to find themselves in
the whole but they're also not able to
find themselves in the action that
they're doing where can they find
themselves then well the answer is they
can't at this point but where can they
seek to find themselves so here there's
a transition Hegel says before the
universal can perform a deed before
there can actually be a response on this
part of this you know as we're calling
it in you know individual action or
eigen link in taunton which which is not
going to be just individual right if it
isn't in fact a universal work or the
work of absolute freedom before I can do
that he says it has to concentrate
itself into the one of individuality now
what the hell does that mean it has to
concentrate itself into the one of
individuality in order for the substance
to become subject in order to have
agency it has to have somebody who it's
working through now we've seen this
discussed at many points in time right
we saw this earlier in the spirit
section in talking about state power how
state power has to actually be
concentrated in whoever is the
government and that can be a number of
people or that can be one person or that
can be all sorts of things in between it
can involve a bureaucracy of people who
are serving the government who are in
some way doing their fair share could
involve vassalage you can involve all
sorts of things but there has to be some
apex of agency someplace where it's not
the buck stops here but rather the
action starts here and what can the
action start with so Hegel is going to
talk about the universal will at this
point the universal will has to be put
into motion by some individual will this
is going to be a real problem
and this is a long-standing problem by
the time that we get to Hegel in
modernity so he says in order to perform
a d8 it must concentrate itself into the
one of individuality and put at the head
put on top an individual
self-consciousness this raises all sorts
of problems right so let's talk about
one of these problems this is something
that Hobbes who is totally aware of this
and thought that this was in fact the
best that we could hope for addresses in
Leviathan he says that when we make a
social contract which we do so as
rational agents to get ourselves out of
this state of nature where life is nasty
brutish and short you know you can read
Leviathan I don't have to go through all
of that we make a social contract as
rational beings not entirely rational
beings but rational enough to recognize
our own irrationality and the
irrationality of that sob down the
street from me who might want to take my
stuff or might think me a threat and
then try to eliminate me or might be
competing with me just for social
prestige or you know as we call it honor
Hobbes call that the motive of vanity we
form a social contract which means that
each of us willingly renounces some
portion of what it is that we desire or
what we might desire in the future we do
so in it so that I give in order that
you will give to me I won't attack you
kill you threaten you take your stuff
you won't do those things to me and
Hobbes lays out a whole bunch of laws of
nature that a rational person ought to
be able to understand but we're not so
rational that we will actually follow
these if there isn't some authority
figure which he calls the sovereign in
place to enforce them and Hobbes gets a
lot of grief in in modern philosophy in
part because you know the situation is
he is he sets it out is a bit simplified
but also because the solution that he
sets in place of the
absolute sovereign was not even
acceptable to some of the absolute
sovereigns of his time in short the
absolute sovereign has complete power
over life and death cannot be opposed
legitimately except you know just try to
preserve your own life and that's within
very very narrow limits gets to decide
what all the other laws are gets to
decide who the magistrates are gets to
decide what the foreign policy is gets
to decide who can teach what when it
comes to social theory so we're talking
about not just political control but
intellectual control as well also its
extends to religion to should mention
now why would we want something like
that because Hobbs says listen otherwise
you're just going to have some arbitrary
despot it's only when you associate in
this way and you have somebody at the
apex who genuinely is a sovereign that
you have something like a universal will
now other people see that and they say
that person still is a despot why did
you pick you know this this guy over
here George to run things and not Fred
or you know Henriette
or whoever else you want to select why
this one person and not a democracy or
at least an aristocracy of sorts Hobbes
thinks that there's a natural logic that
leads to having that sort of one Jean
Jacques Rousseau also talks about the
general will very critical of Hobbes but
he also has a general will that in
certain respects goes beyond the
Hobbesian one saying that it has to
force us to be free now again we can
have this sort of why that group and
their arbitrary choice their arbitrary
power why does the magistrate get to
decide things in this case for us in a
way that is going to contravene our own
individual will that doesn't seem to be
actually contributing to the to a
general or a universal work but just
explore
expropriating it and using it for for
its own whims there's a big problem
isn't it an absolute monarchies so he
says the universal will is only an act
an actual will a will that can decide
things in a self in a one you've got to
have somebody who's in charge there's no
way around it and he says thereby this
is a big problem all other individuals
are excluded from the entirety of this
deed and they only have a limited share
in it so that the deed would not be a
deed of the actual universal
self-consciousness so what this means
he says universal freedom can produce
neither a positive work nor a deed the
this turns out to be a pipe dream there
is no universal work that I can find
myself in there is left for it only
negative action he says it's merely the
fury of destruction so now we're
starting to see the the slide from
absolute freedom which sounded so good
had to happen in some kind of harmony
down into the terror
but the supreme reality and the reality
which stands in the greatest antithesis
to universal freedom or rather the sole
object that will still exist for that
freedom is the freedom and individuality
of actual self consciousness itself for
that universality which does not let
itself advance to the reality of an
organic articulation and whose aim is to
maintain itself in an unbroken
continuity at the same time creates a
distinction within itself because it is
movement or consciousness in general and
moreover by virtue of its own
abstraction it divides itself into
extremes equally abstract into a simple
inflexible cold universality and into
the discrete absolute hard rigidity and
self-willed animism of actual
self-consciousness now that it has
completed the destruction of the actual
organization of the world that exists
now just for itself this is its sole
object an object that no longer has any
content possession existence or outer
extension but is merely this knowledge
of itself is an absolutely pure and free
individual self all that remains of the
object by which it can be laid hold up
is solely it's abstract existence as
such the relation none of these two
since each exists indivisibly and
absolutely for itself and thus cannot
dispose of a middle term which would
link them together is one of wholly
unmediated pure negation a negation
moreover of the individual as being
existing in the in diverse 'el the sole
work indeed of universal freedom is
therefore death a death to which has no
inner significance or filling for what
is negated as the empty point of the
absolutely free self it is thus the
coldest and meanest of all deaths which
no more sync with no more significance
than cutting off a head of cabbage or
swallowing a mouthful of water
paragraph 590 ends in a terrible way
which makes perfect sense given that the
entire title and the content of this is
absolute freedom and terror what what is
terror and what is terrible so he was
going to talk about death but he doesn't
just talk about any sort of death he's
going to end by saying we have a death
which has no inner significance or
filling what is negated is the empty
point of the absolutely free self it is
the coldest and meanest of all deaths
which with no more significance than
cutting off a head of cabbage or
swallowing a mouthful of water a death
that has no significance both for the
person who's dying and for the person
who is imposing death or even the one
who is commanding it in some way it
becomes something to tick off a box on a
form so how do we get there well
remember in the last paragraph we found
that the individual self consciousness
could not find itself within the
universal work and at the same time one
person was being elevated to embody the
universal will by the very nature of the
way will has to work so he says the
supreme reality and the reality which
stands in the greatest antithesis to
universal freedom or rather the soul
object that will still exist for that
freedom is what the freedom and
individuality of actual self
consciousness itself it's a convoluted
little line right so we've got this
universal freedom and something is
standing in antithesis to it but is also
he says the soul object that will exist
for it what what can be on its radar so
to speak the absolute freedom the
absolute freedom enjoyed by the the
ruler we have this antithesis
as he's saying at first although it's
not going to turn out to be the normal
kind of antithesis set up between the
universal will and work which is being
steered dominated expropriated by the
one individual the person who really
does enjoy absolute freedom and then the
individual self consciousness and there
there are many of these right but each
one presents a sort of threat insofar as
they're not integrated not just within
to the apparatus of society but in to
the desires into the plans of that one
individual and this is unfair and and
clearly these individuals sense that and
and you can say well you know working
for the greater good our leaders so
brilliant and you know press the intent
taking care of us and yet there's still
that that pardon us that's like screw
them they don't know what what it's like
to live here as a peasant or you know to
work in the factory or to be a soldier
in their army or to be you know doing
the wash or pick whatever you like they
don't understand our actual position
there's a legitimate concern there so he
goes on and he says that universality
which does not let itself advance to the
reality of an organic articulation now
why why does this this not allow itself
to advance as he says to an organic
articulation what would an organic
articulation be something more like the
state as Hegel ultimately envisions that
envisions it later on as you know a
place where everybody every role has its
its particular contribution to make and
understands itself as being part of a
greater whole now that's more of an
ideal than an actuality although we do
enjoy things like that sometimes
although often times we think that we're
that way and then we find somebody
behind the scenes getting the glory
getting the money getting the credit
seeing us around doing what they want
with it many people in today's corporate
environment find themselves getting
screwed over by identifying themselves
with an organization or an institution
thinking that that you know doing their
little part in there is actually
honoured rewarded and will be taken care
of later on only to discover that they
are totally expendable and the boss
doesn't even really know their name so
let's go on with this alright he says it
doesn't let itself advance to the
reality of an organic articulation its
aim is to maintain itself in an unbroken
continuity but it creates a distinction
within itself
Magali and logic here right because it
is movement or consciousness in general
by virtue of its own abstraction he says
it divides itself into extremes equally
abstract notice what he's saying they're
equally abstract extremes the the
general Universal will the governance
the one who's in charge abstract sort of
like the lord of the world earlier the
individual self-consciousness we would
say well that's the most concrete you
can get well it can also be abstract he
talks about atomized individuals here
that is people who understand themselves
as isolated as apart from everybody else
now that goes against the very notion of
self-consciousness that we saw early on
in the self-consciousness section
self-consciousness only is in relation
to another and this doesn't have to be
the only other it could be the other
who's your your parent your child the
person down the street
self-consciousness really exists in
relation to other others but insofar as
it's just a sort of I'm not going to be
told what to do reaction over here it is
abstract so he says we have an
inflexible cold universality and then
the discrete absolute
rigidity and self-willed atom ISM of
actual self consciousness now here's
where things get trickier where the
stakes are raised Hegel talks about the
destroyed actual organization of the
world before if we have this sort of
conflict we could fall back on a world
of culture or a world of faith or
perhaps even a world of the early
enlightenment but all of that through
the the corrosive critique of the
Enlightenment has been dealin amazed we
can no longer fall back on that we're
entering a new era where absolute
freedom could be realized absolute
freedom means none of these institutions
and organizations and ways of
establishing society have complete call
upon us there they don't provide us with
a place to retreat so he says now that
it has completed the destruction of the
actual organization of the world and
exists now just for itself this is its
sole object whose the it their self
consciousness right or absolute freedom
an object that no longer has any content
possession existence or outer extension
but is merely this knowledge of itself
is an absolutely pure and free
individual self so he says all there
remains are the object by which it can
be laid hold of object for what what
what object are we talking about like
money or guns or butter no the object is
self consciousness the object is freedom
what the hell is freedom what what does
this mean to me I can understand it in
another person but that other person is
being treated abstractly very abstractly
we might call this hyper abstraction so
Hegel is telling us that for each person
involved in this the other person the
other other becomes simply an abstract s
existence as such what does this give us
then he says the relation of these two
since each exists indivisibly and
absolutely for itself the one who is in
charge and the one who is not in charge
who has to take the orders we don't have
the same sort of relation as we did say
in the master-slave dialectic and steady
says the relation cannot dispose of a
middle term which would link them
together there is no mediation here
instead there's just negation negation
coming from both sides so he says it's
unmediated pure negation a negation of
the individual as a being existing in
the universal how is this a negation of
the being the individual existing in the
universal well if you kill the one in
charge or if you also say well you're
not really a person anymore
that's a negation of the individual
existing in the universal there's also a
negation of the individual existing in
the universal insofar as the action the
comportment whatever it is that this
contribution is supposed to mean doesn't
really provide them with anything but
there's another way to in which the
universal here can negate the individual
and that is through death he says the
sole work indeed of universal freedom is
death
and this is a death that no longer has
some sort of locus of meaning it's just
a wiping things out a settling scores
it's a bureaucratic death we might say
so are we get at the terror not yet but
we're getting very close
you